yeah one thing you said that kind of
reminded me was I remember when when
Trump was running for office and Bill
bich that asked him about him and he
said that's my friend I support my
[__] friend you know like whatever
you guys think about it is fine like
because he wrote a letter to him telling
him congratulations for running I think
was that is that what happened and um
what are you talking about uh it was
when Donald Trump was running for office
right and they and Bill bich had written
him a letter that just said hey congrats
on running for president right and I
think Trump mentioned it and then the
media attacked bich about it but he said
hey that's my friend I support my friend
yeah yeah and people need to be able to
stand up I think it's yeah I think
people a lot of people are in fear
because I'm having breakfast with him
tomorrow on his plane he's my friend
right we talk all the time we talk about
fights so he he called me up uh right
after Abu Dhabi and said those rides are
great oh my God the vul uh you know um
is yeah I met him twice at your events
man exactly it was great he's a great
guy he's you know it was the politics
are dirty man it's nasty it's ugly you
know and uh like all the [__] that's
going on right with him right now if he
wasn't running they wouldn't be doing
any of this stuff to him none of this
would be happening and if he wasn't in
the lead like he's going to win the
election none of this would be happening
to him right now so yeah it just it is
what it is and and the guy's always been
an amazing friend to me he and I will be
friends for the rest of our lives yeah
yeah I'm I'm glad I got to meet him
that's the first President I ever got to
meet you know I would support any of our
presidents you know yeah I always well
I'm that guy too you know I'm I don't
I'm I'm not volatile over politics man
this is America you can vote for whoever
you want you could be on either side of
the of the political Spectrum I don't
care I don't judge you by your politics
I judge what type of a person you are
yeah yeah and if you think the
government's going to save your life
dude I've always said this me to the
government you were they're just a f
these people that want the you want less
government you want them out of your
life you do not want the government and
the government's never going to take
care of you yeah never going to get rich
off the government dude no dude stamp
collections get [__] H me right the
post office is almost out of business
dude have you been to the post office
recently they just tell you how to get
to wherever you want your mail to go
dude I'll say this it's uh yeah there's
nothing tougher than uh there's nothing
more ridiculous than expecting the
government but I think we're in a weird
space now where we're between the
government that we've been used to and a
new kind of privatized communism almost
so I think we're in this weird space of
almost two governments where one is like
a almost a sh like a shadow well there's
a battle going on right now there's
there there's a there's a war there is
going on uh in the government one that
wants to go one way that most of us
don't want to go and one that wants to
keep things the way they are yeah it
might be broken and [__] up and needs
to be fixed but um we're definitely in
that weird place right now I agree so
get off your pelons boys and let's
[__] go to war love it imagine and
this happened to me too this this
happened to me I posted a video for
Trump right on my personal social media
and one of our big sponsors called and
said take that down you know what I said
go [__] yourself yeah you vote for
whoever you want to vote for and I'll
vote for whoever I want to vote for
that's how this works I don't even care
who you're voting for it's none of my
[__] business [__] you yeah don't
never [__] call me and tell me who to
vote for yeah yeah yeah I think a lot of
people feel in fear these days you know
a lot of people feel in fear that if
they don't vote for certain people
they're going to lose their jobs I mean
it's Hollywood for example think about
how [__] crazy that is it sounds
insane it sounds just like well it'll
keep happening unless more people stand
up for themselves and give them the [__]
you response what about so when you deal
with like how has it been harder because
you guys are part of William Morris
right I work with them right they're
pretty company right
woke as woke can be yeah yeah I think
it's woke Morris entertainment or
something you know it should be anyway
but um yeah they're [__] woke they're
always crazy we had Tucker Carlson on
the other day and they're all [__]
I'm sure you know or whatever putting on
their maxi pads but um I love Tucker too
yeah Tucker's [__] fascinating is
dude awesome I'm actually going to
dinner with him here in the next uh next
few weeks yeah he's it was interesting I
didn't know what it would be like you
know he looks like a guy that you know
uh gets dressed at John and Murphy in
the airport every day you know but um he
was really really cool yeah he's a great
dude smart guy too really smart yeah it
was fun toist I don't judge people by
their politics or or their race or their
religions or any of that [__] there's uh
you're either a douchebag or you're not
a douchebag and and if you're a
douchebag I want nothing to do with you
if you're a good person I don't care who
you vote for what who you sleep with or
what religion you are I don't care about
any of that
[__]
that